We're at a crossing. Can you
feel this? Can you touch the
fear and dizziness of our
moment? Can you sense the ground
shifting beneath you? The sky
spinning as a red tail swipes
the stars from the heavens.
Everything is changing. Right now.
There's no going back
anymore. All is getting shaky,
but all is getting clamped down.
All is being liberated. While
all is being tracked. All is
permitted, while the inquisitor
looms behind you. Two sides have
risen, insuperable opposites with
no medium to join them. The
extremes are weighing in and all
reality is caught between
Charybdis and Scylla. You see,
they told us the world was just
a cacophony of colliding
particles. That love was just an
injection of hormones and
instincts. They told us the
heavens were cold and dead, that
the fairies were our ancestors'
delusions. They convinced us art
was the framing of random facts
and objects. They told us our
stories and rituals were only
power games and superstitions.
They made us into desire
machines, no closer to the gods
than the beasts. In fact, the
gods do not exist. The angels,
the jinns, the demons, the
woodland sprites do not exist.
They're superstition. The world
is a wound up clock running out.
And in the end, you are a wound
up clock running out into
nothingness. You can't try to
kill all the gods and then still
expect to live, can you? They
mocked, they derided, they
dissected. And now our world is
being ripped apart. Now who
could have seen this coming? Who
could have thought that in
defiling our stories and
demonizing our orders and
reducing all that made us one,
to the quantities that embodied
that unity. Who would have
thought that that would fragment
us? That it would fragment our
societies, our vision, that it
would twist our virtues into
innumerable empty desires. But
this is where we stand, isn't
it? We look around us and we
watch the story unravel. We
watch our commonalities fall
apart, as people are at each
other's throats. First,
virtually, but more and more in
the flesh. And so what can we
do? We're supposed to be
artists. But it's partly our
fault that this has happened.
Maybe not you and I. But let's
say the artists. We are supposed
to be the guardians of stories.
We are supposed to be those who
enchant the world. But for
several hundred years now, it is
us who have played the part in
making everything arbitrary and
making everything random, in
playing around beauty as if it
was just a frivolous fantasy of
individuals. And so it's partly
our fault.
And it's partly our fault as
Christians as well. In many ways
we have assaulted the world of
meaning. We have assaulted the
enchanted world. As Christians
we in the West have been part of
those who have removed the
angels from the heavens, who
have chased the sprites out of
the forests. It's us who did
that. And now we live with the
consequences of our actions.
But hope is not completely lost.
We do stand here in a very dark
moment. We do stand in the dark
room with strange eerie sounds,
coming from that darkness. But
all hope is not lost. We know of
this story. We know of this
story of a man who went into
death and surprised everybody by
entering there. We know this
story of someone who went into
death and death thought that it
had won. Death thought that in
bringing that man who is also
God into its belly, that it had
won. But it grabbed life. And
the trick was played on it. And
I believe that we can
participate in that trick. Right
now, all of us, all of us who
are artists and who believe in
that story, who live by that
story, or at least have the
pretence of living by that
story. There's an opportunity
for us right now. Because in
this strange darkness there are
strange creepy crawly things
that are coming up. The world is
being re-enchanted. The
atheists, the secularists, they
were wrong. The world cannot
exist without meaning. It is
impossible. Every single
capacity we have to even
recognise something as having
being is already a participation
in meaning. Their war on meaning
cannot be won.
But as all of our stories have
been shattered and broken apart,
it has given room for all the
dark things to come back up
first. And those are the things
we're starting to see appear on
our horizon. The old gods are
coming back and not even the
interesting old gods. But those
darker gods, the ones that don't
have clear identities, those
strange hybrid monsters that
lived on the edge of the world,
they're the ones that are
crawling back into the world
first. And as artists we have an
opportunity. Because we know the
story, especially as Christian
artists, we know the story. We
know the story of the world. We
know what happens next. There's
always a spark hidden in the
darkness. There's always a lit
candle in that darkest place.
Because without that lit candle,
things simply do not exist. The
Word of God is hidden in
creation. And it is our job to
find it, and it is our job as
artists to help the world see
that flicker. And there is an
opportunity, because a strange
thing is happening in culture.
As Christianity is being
evacuated from the public
sphere. As our story is being
tossed aside, it is nonetheless
filling the world at the same
time. And this is a mystery
that, even a few decades ago
people could not see the strange
mystery of death. The strange
mystery of Christ entering in
the tomb we have the opportunity
of seeing it happen right now,
because as the Christian story
is being evacuated, we are
noticing that it's reappearing
in all the strangest places.
Because the bright light of
Christ is no longer so visible,
all of a sudden these small
sparkles are starting to appear
hidden in the cavern walls. And
we see this story of Christ in
the strangest places we see some
stupid superhero movie where the
superhero falls to the ground
and dies and then rises again.
And we see another strange
popular story coming up of
someone sacrificing themselves
for others, giving themselves
for the weakest. We see twisted
versions of people who are
willing to do everything to
bring up the weaker part of our
world, to bolster it and to help
it. And where do you think those
lights come from? And so we have
an opportunity. But we also have
a responsibility. Meaning is
inescapable and we have
responsibility towards it. It is
a weight that we have to carry
as artists. It is a very
daunting responsibility that we
have right now as the world
descends into darkness, that we
are the ones who can give it a
little bit of hope. We are the
ones that can point those little
sparks, those small lights,
those twisted versions of the
true light, that we are the ones
who can point it back to the one
true light and origin of our
world.
And so I just wanted to maybe
give people a challenge. And I
know all of you watching this
are probably artists. So I want
to give you that challenge. To
jump into that story. To not
think that the story of Christ
is just the story we believe in
to be saved. But to truly jump
into that story, and realise
that that story is also the
story of everything. It is the
story of creation. It is the
story of how things exist. The
story of Christ is the fullest
manifestation of every other
story that have been told since
the beginning of time. And so it
is our responsibility to jump
into that and to redistribute it
to the world in ways that point
towards that great story. So I
want to thank you for your
attention today. And I hope that
all of us can grasp that
challenge, that opportunity and
also that responsibility